Ryan how are you this morning I'm
looking forward to our bucking my friend
how are you it'll be great uh what
should i bring you know when you go to
off to sleep away camp you always bring
something so what can I count on with
you bringing I suggest a little beat a
little bug hugs ray hello buddy is a
little deep so you go down saturday i go
friday yeah what's up again yeah well I
well come from Los Angeles where you
going from New York okay so it is uh
it's Friday that'll be in over the
weekend we should definitely connect i'm
looking for to going down i guess i
should be asking you what do i need to
know on the newbie for these things no
you did great london a good time yeah i
loved i love tell london put this
together but anytime you say that you're
going to the Olympics everybody says
what about that Zika virus so yeah I've
run out of answers what are you saying
when people ask you about Rio and the
Zika virus well I you know I talked to I
several doctors about it both myself and
also on my radio show and uh you know I
think it's a little bit more hyped in
the media than than the actual concern
is on the ground so I'm not worried
about that much I'm actually excited to
get there I think it's gonna be a lot of
fun of you fantastic games and so not a
lot of worries my biggest concern is
just make sure I know exactly how to
talk about sports well but because I
took the advice I got was how Michaels
told me and you should take this because
it helped me in London is deal in half
hour increments all you do is deal with
the next half hour whether it's judo or
it's you know women's gymnastics it's
the next half hour that you deal with
and if you do it in increments then you
not only way through it yeah well I
every day that the doorbell rings and
there's a new binder from NBC reminders
yes I must have 15 different white
binders three-ring binders and stacked
up of events and pronunciations and
names and stories and athletes not only
the US but around the world are you
getting these things yeah but I'm not as
worried about the other athletes around
the world I think if there's something
amazing that happens then you worry
about I still go back to a half hour at
a time because I was overwhelmed when I
when I went to London I'm thinking I
can't
process all of this information yeah and
we know capacity capacity only about
five six man yes I said I I said I can't
do this and I'll goes don't do half hour
and then you get ready for the next
event yeah and if you do it that way do
do we get to do anything together you
die now because you got super models
like I don't eat like you don't need to
you got lima and and imbrose you Ambrose
here yeah you're a hoarder you're a
supermodel quarter you know I I was uh
actually on vacation for a couple of
days when the press release came out I
had no idea I read the press release
when it came out just like you did I had
no idea that they were working on
assigning them to me I didn't know we're
working at NBC but I read a press
release and dot this is fantastic in my
first this is true one of the first just
looking at what they sent me remember
one of the first assignments that i may
do with them and you're welcome to come
along because maybe you'll you'll love
be into this is with adriana and
Alessandra how to make a bikini oh come
on Ryan who is one of the first stories
that one invite you to do with me how to
make a bikini all right I'll get alert
are you there yeah I'll do it I'll do it
okay yeah I come yeah I come along tag
along do you even know these women I
think I met them before I don't know of
course you have I've met them before
somewhere I did see we do initial will
you be doing this show from there no no
they weren't gonna let me do it and we
were trying to do it they they won't let
me do it okay are you doing your show
there I'm doing mine from there yeah you
know great yeah yeah that's awkward
we're talking to Ryan Seacrest the ryan
seacrest i saw this quote and I didn't
think I'd ever see this quote attached
to you that you would knock the crap out
of people in high school when you played
football well first let's go back to I
play football I think that surprising a
lot of people listening to show I uh I
grew up actually playing center on the
offensive line short snapping long
snapping moved to pulling guard
I moved to linebacker and then I lost
weight became strong safety so I
actually grew up playing football and I
didn't have a lot of technique of
finesse or skill so just try and stay as
the coaches just trying stickam you know
so that was that that's about all i
could do or try to do on the field but
uh if people pretty surprised when they
hear that i owned a pair cleats but you
also played at a good football school
where did you go to you weren't uh was a
dunwoody dunwoody in uh you just outside
Atlanta Georgia yeah like they they want
to state championship before right yeah
they I think they can see James you we
got really close my senior year and then
I think I fumble the ball but you know
we got close my fault yeah learn so I
didn't I did not know that you were
what's official height and weight of
Ryan Seacrest the official hiding right
now one on the license is 510 oh that's
a lie yeah that's a that's a lot I'm
telling you know that's why prices 510
160 the truth is let me go oh yeah god I
was gonna go go I was going to go five
seven and a half okay and I was gonna go
150 to once again Dan you're an inch shy
and you are four pounds you're giving me
four pounds that um I'm trying to drop
it oh you are and by the way you can't
do this like when we were just hanging
out in London like you kill it with the
Wardrobe thing like you wake up it
almost felt like you were in a suit and
your hair was prone you never wear
sweatpants or anything so I always feel
like my wife would say wait are you
supposed to be dressed up i don't know
he's not supposed to be dressed up well
the reason I'm dressed up is because I
didn't know what I was supposed to be
doing yell at any given time I thought
they'd ask me to go you know run over
here cover this do that so I was the
guide was kind of just ready to go and
do whatever they ask me to do that's why
I was always I think I laid in my bed in
that stuffer had a real awesome because
literally I get a call run over and
cover this run ever talk to Matt run
over talk too damn i was just I was like
utility player you know James what was
your first media job my first media job
was uh I was a kid I used to drive down
to the radio station in Atlanta and this
is like
I'll be dropped off action by my mother
was 15 but I would sit in the studio and
pull the cartridges the carts is it
called the songs for the DJ stack them
up in the right order and then I began
to get an internship at the station
called star before in Atlanta and after
that when I was in high school had a
driver's license I drove down there was
the weekend DJ I was in high school so I
was the first job in media but I've been
going to a radio station every day of my
life every week day of my life since I
was 16 years old on 41 now you still
heavily involved with the Kardashians
I'm seeing them later today okay but I
send a message what is your bro I'll
give my best to Khloe I love Chloe she's
a great yes he's great i think she'd be
the one I would want to hang out with
his boys she's very funny if you had a
ride if you happy I I talked to right
right I think she's very funny I I think
spin great says here I don't know you
know like dis Kanye ever smile I think
that's because he does that yeah he does
he does he's intense he's an intense guy
you know I think that when he's in his
uh creative focus own he's in that zone
you know is there everybody no not the
kind you know just say just say what up
easy you know just I think that's why I
need to say uh is there a topic that's
ever been off limits like you've thought
about that with the Kardashians and then
you stayed away with stay away from you
kinda runs itself now we first started I
remember looking at episodes of the show
and uh it was new to the e network and
the things that they were saying I
thought how we cannot we should probably
keep this in we should edit this out you
know they we can put this on cable
course everything's evolved so far and
then I realized it that the voice that
they have the voices they use the things
that they talk about that's really will
make them them so you you we don't
filter sure we fill to the obvious
things but we don't filter nearly as
much as we thought we had to at the
beginning but you know they're all
producers on the show so they they get
they do it I don't think you know people
say a lot of things about them I don't
think that they get enough credit for
the amount of hours that they put in to
do things I'm sure they're filming they
realize but they also work outside of
that quite a bit and they've never
showed up late they've never called in
sick ever in the decade or so working
with
so i I'm I'm an advocate I like them a
lot obviously if you could date a
Kardashian which one would you did a
great question they're all set up okay I
tell you is not rob okay not rapidly
little see that it would not be right by
the way is the blac Chyna rob situation
gonna survive your run I don't know
we're in the midst of shooting that as
it may surprise you but no I think it's
overrun it's over between the two you do
know y absolutely what makes you think
that what's what was the impetus then I
Brian it just it's just a savvy baby i
am with it the individual medley is that
what yes yes yes yet i am again even
though she's pregnant you know I just I
feel like that's best for you look at
you plugged in a TMZ live aren't you yes
I am absolutely absolutely I you know
sports is a hobby Ryan what will the
family be there in in real oh yeah you
know see if we get some stragglers there
they want to want to join me there so go
back to everybody single which
Kardashian are you dating nice try to
get out of the answer there yeah yeah
yeahs would have to be between Kim Khloe
Kourtney and in Rio I'll reveal Who am I
don't hide by the way this is this is
such a fantasy world cuz they're not and
um you know they've got far better
choices in selections and in this
discussion or male oh come on hello i
got my i would date Khloe because she's
gonna be your song ever yeah she's gonna
fun i I'm gonna have a wild ride while
I'm there and um you know until their
mom kicks me out let me let me ask you
did who would your wife want you today
mmm Caitlyn all of them Caitlyn yeah I
think Caitlyn Jenner mmm experience
wisdom yeah wicked talk sports I'd I had
Bruce on well when he was when he was
bruised and i think was four years ago
and I I said do the your kids even know
about your greatness as an Olympian he
said well their boyfriends want me they
want to wear my Olympic medal they think
it's like cool you know so that they
want to like wear it out and he said you
know so I don't know if they know what I
did they
no I have this cool piece of jewelry
there they would like to wear out if I
wearing people yeah I'd like to have
some bling can I have your uh yeah they
they like Miss accessories those medals
yeah have you ever played golf with some
Kentucky you know I have not and I'm
just a terrible golfer uh I'm not I'm
not that good at it I I tried a couple
times when I was growing up in the South
but I just haven't had a chance to
really focus I'm not a great golfer so I
haven't spent time on the course with
Caitlyn yeah he invited me to play it
sure would and uh but now as Caitlyn he
says he gets too t.t awfully decline I
couldn't get there and when he wanted me
to play got it but now that he could see
it from the women's tees I have no
chance of beating Caitlyn yeah yeah i'm
not sure but are you are you're you're
good at golf I'm I'm uh I'm decent but
yeah yeah but I'd like to play yeah like
I'm not a chance it to do that you gotta
pick up in your claw to get the time yet
to get time to actually develop a hobby
that's first goal all right uh safe
travels and then oh yeah i'll touch base
with you when i get in over the weekend
yeah that'll be nice that'd be nice to
see you again right and let me on good
luck you two thanks for dr. it's a ryan
seacrest the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience